what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and one
of the questions that receive from you
guys cuz I was looking through the
comments of the Ironman god killer armor
video which by the way one day I want to
sit down I know this sounds crazy one
day I want to sit down I want to like I
want to teach LeBron James about comics
like I do I think that'd be so cool
so just like like LeBron James like King
James I want to sit down and just be
like hey man you want to learn about
Marvel Comics I have no reason to
believe he'd be interested he just be
like man I ain't got time to worry about
Marvel Comics I'm making money playing
basketball son I feel like you wouldn't
really care but I think it'd be kind of
a cool thing like to talk to LeBron
James about comics but nonetheless so I
was with or I'm sorry I was looking
through the comments that you guys had
and somebody well there were a lot of
people who were just like that's
ridiculous you know that's whatever but
somebody had made a comment they were
like so we probably won't see like a
25,000 foot tall god-killer armor but
what if we saw like a Thanos Buster
armor and it kind of got me thinking
because it like in mobile comics that
Thanos Buster armor doesn't really exist
there's no such thing as an armor that
that I a man made to combat fan o's but
there are armors that he has that can do
it and that's kind of the cool thing is
is really just like kind of realistic
and renaming certain types of armor most
notably the Thor Buster armor that's the
only one that I can think of that would
probably be able to just be like Thanos
buster and they could do that they could
take the Thor buster concept from Marvel
Comics and they could roll it over into
the into the MCU and just call the
Thanos Buster suit that he specifically
makes and there's a couple ways that
they can get away with that Thor would
be the easiest way to to essentially
make that happen but here's here's an
interesting thing
so the first question to really ask here
is if we take fan o's and we say how
powerful is thin O's that's an ambiguous
question it's kind of an interesting
situation on the whole Marvel actually
like if you know where to look in Marvel
Comics they'll tell you how powerful
characters are like for example they
tell you how powerful Thanos is um what
Marvel does is occasionally they used to
do it all the time back in the 90s they
don't really do it anymore I want to say
the last time they did it was with
Mighty Avengers and even then it had
been something like maybe six years
before they done it up to that point but
what Marvel does is they'll release
basically one shots and they're
essentially just files is all they are
and you can find a lot of fun you can
find like the Charles Xavier or the
Professor Xavier
protocols for the x-men like how to kill
the different members of the x-men
if they end up going to ride with their
powers or something like that um I think
you have Williams strikers x-men files
where he was a crazy religious guy who
believed that God wanted to kill mutants
one of the best villains ever in the
history of model that's an example of a
villain who's more interesting than the
heroes like William Stryker was really
really intriguing like his his
motivation the way he was written was
really cool Marvel would never be able
to publish a story with him today people
would freak out but like back then like
back in the 80s and even going out like
more recently in the mid-2000s William
Stryker was really really intriguing but
but you also have things like like Adam
Brashear for example blue Marvel you've
got a file on him it's only for King
Hyperion I'm pretty sure King Iberian
was a was a villain was a character who
killed all the cosmic entities and all
the superheroes in his own universe and
then showed up in the main Marvel
Universe
it was pretty beastly he was he was
pretty powerful uh but what you had in
2006 is you had a story called
annihilation and annihilation I mean we
don't really need to go too deep into it
for this video but it was basically a
story that took place at the same time
as Marvel Civil War and it was
essentially a scenario where all these
different were really like the whole
universe banded against an invading you
know an invasion force more or less from
a guy named Annihilus although at least
everybody except for Earth's who are
superheroes they were dealing with civil
war it's kind of a funny situation when
you compare them and like the tie-ins
for annihilation into civil war but
nonetheless it's part of annihilation
Marvel released a one-shot called the
annihilation core files and when Marvel
releases the fought these files they're
contextual based on who the villains of
of that particular file belongs to so
with the Nova Corps they are a cosmic
group they're basically like a cosmic
police force their Marvel's equivalent
of the Green Lantern Corps and so
because of that what they in turn did is
they said okay here's basically one you
know here's a little joint one shot
comic with files and information on the
various characters that exist on the
cosmic level so Galactus and the cosmic
entities and mistress death basically
everybody involved in in the events of
annihilation Thanos was listed among
them and Thanos was defined as universal
level now here's the problem
Marvel doesn't really quantify why
Thanos is a universal level threat they
don't really say he's a universal level
threat because he can just manipulate
that much cosmic energy because he's
part eternal which is something that I
hope we really see in the Eternals MCU
movie is characters who can just
manipulate cosmic energies or
that he's a universe level threat
because of the fact that he just has
this unending desire to destroy all
things in existence he's had the Cosmic
Cube he's had the Infinity Gauntlet he
just had all these insane sources of
power and he's destroyed all life or at
least trying to destroy all life on more
than one occasion so they don't really
quantify that they just simply defy him
define him as a universal level threat
having said that when you look at the
nature of Thanos himself and you look at
the things he's done it bounces around
he's defeated the Silver Surfer he
defeated Thor in the Incredible Hulk and
Jonathan Hickman's infinity he has a lot
of power but it's not as though he's
this unstoppable immutable force in his
base form with no Infinity Gauntlet or
Cosmic Cube if I were a betting man
we're gonna use this as an example if I
were a betting man I would say that if
you took like part of the monster Hulk
for example a version of The Incredible
Hulk that was so strong that his
strength had the ability to like
fracture and damaged dimensions because
he was just so so it's just such raw
extreme strength Thanos will get readily
just get absolutely decimated but for
this example we want to talk about Odin
if Thanos fought Odin Thanos would get
wrecked that's that's I mean that to me
that's that's not really an arguable
point I mean they don't Odin is just
that powerful because he has the
odinforce which is kind of Marvel's
excuse to allow him to do anything he
wants to in comic books it's the life
force of his two dead brothers but it's
the fact that he's able to basically
manipulate all these Asgardian energies
um depending on the situation Odin may
you know may lose like for example in
the Infinity Gauntlet story you had a
meeting of the sky fathers and sky
fathers well as you guys who don't know
and I know I'm dumping a lot of
information on you guys but the sky
fathers are basically Earth's gods that
are on part of this this kind of council
and when I say Earth's gods I mean
either a singular God that like a group
race - or like a pantheon of gods led by
one person so for example the sky
fathers consists of people like Odin and
Zeus and Vishnu different things like
that you know that that whole idea even
like Egyptian gods have appeared there
before and so the idea was that like
during the events of Infinity Gauntlet
they were like we have we can't do
anything here we can try but like this
is a dude with a power to destroy the
entirety of the universe with a snap of
mr. Lee's manipulate the you know I'm
sorry destroy all life in the universe
rather where the staff of his finger
there's nothing we can do that us only
kill half but like he could kill at all
you wanted to is it's just it's just
that powerful so there wasn't really
anything they could do but Odin in and
of himself is exceedingly powerful now
getting into you know some I guess seven
minutes later getting into the actual
meat and potatoes of this whole thing
when it comes to the Thor Buster sue
this may disappearance back in 2003 with
Iron Man vol three issue number actually
was an Iron Man and Thor crossover and
it was called standoff it was a
three-part crossover I want to say it
was Thor fifty two Iron Man vol three 64
and then Thor fifty three but the idea
was that this came out of the events of
of the death of Odin leading up to
Ragnarok when Dan Jergens was riding the
Thor stories and with Odin having been
killed the mantle of controlling you
know basically being a leader of Asgard
passed to Thor who in turn inherited the
odinforce and had like you know the
hammer and all that kind of good stuff
what ended up happening is there was a
village in a place called slick oviya
and this village was basically being
like not really ransacked but it was a
place where people had basically sworn
allegiance to the Asgardians I think and
they were essentially like hunted down
and exterminated by the existing
paramilitary and you know at the time
and so the result was that Heimdall saw
what was going on he told Thor Thor
responded and it was going to set off an
international incident and so Ironman
responded and said hey you have to stand
down Thor said dude get out of here I'm
literally going to kill every last one
of these soldiers and so Ironman
retreated and it was really cool he goes
back to his base of operations and he
meets with Pepper Potts and Pepper Potts
is you know Ironman is like we need to
use this little char this little shard
of Asgardian energy that Thor gave me
once upon a time and I'm gonna use it to
power a suit and like an Pepper Potts is
like yeah but like you don't know you
don't know where that came from and you
don't really know what it does and it's
like well it channel's the powers of s
guardian energies and no I don't really
know where it came from and that's it
that's the only explanation we ever get
about it we never find out like like
what this thing is or like how deep it
goes or any of that stuff we're just
told it's a shard of Asgardian
energy that allows you know a person who
wields it to manipulate Asgardian energy
itself and so the result is that Iron
Man puts it in a suit that's designed to
look like to destroy your armor and then
shows up and goes head-to-head against
Thor now this battle is intense it's
Iron Man in this this Thor buster suit
he faces off against the war wielding
the odinforce he's able to stop the stop
the hammer for dead in its trucks like
the same way that hella did except that
it doesn't get destroyed like it did in
the movie
it's insane and so what this meant was
that that Iron Man using the Thor Buster
suit could stand off against against
Thor wielding the power of the odinforce
but it's not a definitive answer right I
mean like like you look at that whole
thing and it's like okay well one they
were on earths maybe Thor I didn't wanna
destroy Earth by using the entirety of
the odinforce but it's not like it's a
huge broadsword right it's not like you
just kind of swing it and whatever hits
you no ever gets hit gets hit you know
that you can fine-tune it and use it use
it necessarily and so because of that I
would say that if we if we and I I hate
power scaling because comics change all
the time nothing is an absolute but when
you when you take the when you take this
idea of like using you know saying Thor
can never defeat Odin and then in turn
you know to say that like Iron Man could
basically stalemate Thor with the
odinforce then you can kind of make this
compare and contrast and sort of fit the
pieces in as you want to and then in
turn basically say like they could
essentially come to like an even battle
between you or at the very least like a
Thor buster suit could be modified
essentially created by Iron Man kicking
back Thanos but here's a problem is
Stannis is basically wielding the
Infinity Gauntlet and in truth I kind of
stand by the opinion I don't believe the
Infinity Gauntlet is less powerful than
it was before it wouldn't make any sense
to call them Infinity stones if they
only had a finite amount of energy or if
you just did one great big huge thing
then it reduces the amount of energy
their Infinity stones it's infinite
energy it's not finite energy and so
because of that like I think the Gaul is
just as great as it ever was um I think
that if you saw something like a Thanos
Buster suit you would be there just for
the sake of having it there I don't
really think you would go on to see it
like actually you know single-handedly
defeat Thanos I think it'd be cool but
even then like with the whole idea of
like Asgard and all that kind of stuff
because we know from the Russo brother
interviews that like Valkyrie and all
them are still around and like like half
of the Asgardian forces they're so or at
least out there somewhere so I mean like
like we know that like the remnants of
Asgard still exist at least if only in
the form of the people I mean there's
there's a zillion things they could do
for example instead of having like you
know a shard of the Asgardian energy you
literally have Iron Man join with Thor
and they take off to the forge of Nadav
lair and they basically built a new Iron
Man suit out of all that energy and
that's that's what it turns into or at
least created like take a shard of that
energy and then put it into an
Ironman suit there's a zillion ways they
can get around you know in order to make
that work but that's why I say I mean
these whole theory things are kind of
cool because I feel like with something
like Avengers 4 we're talking about a
movie that's 10 years in the making and
I have a hard time believing they're not
gonna pull out all the stops when it
comes to like launching this this great
big huge crazy film I think it's a cool
idea I think it's kind of interesting
basically taking the Thor Buster suit
from Marvel Comics modifying it calling
it a Thanos Buster suit having it made
by some different way and then in turn
letting it loose on Thanos um again I
think with the Infinity Gauntlet the the
suit would get wrecked but it would be
cool to see but with that being said
guys let me know what you all think cuz
I think it's kind of a cool idea let me
know what you guys think about that and
yeah we're gonna and bring this video to
an end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
port and if you enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and then we'll
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
you